bonsoir alors j'aimerais commencer en
vous parlant d'un film ce film bienvenue
à gattaca pour ceux parmi vous qui ne
l'aurait jamais vu il s'agit d'un film
d'anticipation dans lequel le spectateur
est projeté dans un monde hautement
technologique ou l'eugénisme est devenue
la norme
on sélectionne les gamètes des parents
afin de concevoir des enfants sur mesure
ont choisi le sexe la taille la couleur
des yeux et on élimine tout
prédisposition génétique gênante pour ne
conserver que des individus parfait tant
physiquement qu'intellectuellement et
quant aux rares individus en corner de
manière naturelle
ils sont immédiatement relégué au rang
d'un valide où ils exercent des tâches
subalternes
pourquoi je vous parle de ce film parce
qu'en 2011
ce film a été lu par la nasa film de
science fiction le plus plausible de
l'histoire du cinéma et que aujourd'hui
en 2020 la science fiction semble avoir
rejoint la réalité du moins en partie
deux exemples pour vous en convaincre le
premier se passe du côté de los angeles
ou l'institut de la fertilité propose
aux parents contre quelques centaines de
milliers de dollars de choisir les
caractéristiques génétiques de leur
futur enfant
deuxième exemple de l'autre côté du
globe
un généticien chinois a annoncé fin 2010
8 avoir donné naissance au premier bébé
ogm deux jumelles surnommée lulu et nana
alors le généticien a révélé avoir
employé la technique du ciseau
moléculaire pour conférer aux fillettes
une immunité génétique contre le virus
du sida
sauf qu'en réalité des études
postérieures ont démontré que ces
modifications génétiques avaient conduit
à une augmentation de leurs capacités
cognitives
en bref aujourd'hui dans la sélection
que la modification embryonnaires sont
devenus des réalités quelque part dans
le monde et elle pourrait même si on en
croit laurent alexandre devenir la norme
sous l'influencé du courant
transhumanistes alors le transhumanisme
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un mouvement
de pensée qui nous vient de la silicon
valley et qui promeut l'amélioration et
le dépassement des capacités
logique de l'être humain grâce à la
convergence de ce qu'on appelle les ntic
pour nanotechnologies biotechnologies
sciences cognitives et sciences de
l'information et donc ce dont je
voudrais parler avec vous ce soir c'est
de quelques unes des raisons pour lequel
pour lesquels pardon le droit et
l'éthique s'intéresse à l'émergence des
idées transhumanistes alors pour bien
saisir ce qui est le mouvement de pensée
transhumanistes il faut comprendre que
c'est un mouvement de pensée qui
s'articule autour de différents axes
idéologique et chacun de ces axes
idéologique va poser au droit une série
de questions premier acte idéologique
l'obsolescence de l'homme c'est l'idée
que l'homme naturel l'homo sapiens est
devenu obsolète
il est obsolète et pour pallier cette
obsolescence
il convient non plus seulement de
réparer l'homme malade ou abîmées mais
il convient désormais d'améliorer
l'homme en bonne santé en l'augmentant
alors cette augmentation elle peut avoir
lieu à deux niveaux elle peut avoir lieu
au stade embryonnaire c'est ce dont on
vient de parler juste avant et dans ce
cas là elle concernera l'humanité tout
entière
l'espèce humaine et puis elle peut avoir
lieu à un niveau plus individuelle dans
ce cas là elle passera par l'hybridation
entre l'homme et la technique
donc concrètement comment ça va marcher
et bain par exemple on pourra implanter
sur un homme en bonne santé une rétine
artificielle afin qu'ils puissent avoir
une vision nocturne infrarouge
on pourrait sinon à planter sur le corps
d'un homme un troisième bras robotique
qui serait dirigée par le cerveau et qui
permettrait par exemple de soulever
plusieurs tonnes ce que n'est pas
capable de faire actuellement un brun
naturel
aujourd'hui il ya déjà des techniques
des technologies qui existent ou qui
sont en cours de développement qui
peuvent être utilisés dans une
perspective transhumanistes c'est-à-dire
dans une perspective d'augmentation et
ya même des gens qu'on appelle des bodys
hackers qui pratiquent déjà
l'augmentation sur eux mêmes le plus
connu d'entre eux c'est kevin warwick
qui est cybernéticiens anglais et qui
est célèbre notamment pour avoir entre
autres expériences réalisées une forme
de télécommunications de communication
pardon télépathiques
avec son épouse grâce à des puces
implantées directement dans leur système
nerveux respectifs alors les situations
qui vont intéresser le droit ce ne sont
pas tant des situations comme celle de
kevin warwick
ce sont plutôt des situations dans
lesquelles un tiers va intervenir
très concrètement je vous donne un
exemple vous en avez peut-être entendu
parler en 2016 une entreprise belge a
proposé à ses employés de se faire à ses
employés volontaires de se faire
implanter une puce sous la main pour
pouvoir pointer d'un geste de la main
leur arrivée au boulot ou tout
simplement pour pouvoir régler la
cantine plus facilement plus rapidement
les questions que nous juristes on se
pose c'est est ce que demain un tiers
que ce soit du coup un employeur mais
aussi pourquoi pas une compagnie
d'assurance est ce que demain un tiers à
la possibilité d'exiger d'imposer que
moi je mente et je mérite avec la
machine autre exemple si demain moi je
veux mouvementée c'est mon souhait je
souhaite me faire amputer un bras qui
fonctionne mont brun naturel pour le
faire remplacer par une prothèse
bionique beaucoup plus performante tout
simplement en ai-je le droit et si oui
je le droit de d'imposer à quelqu'un un
tiers par exemple un médecins qu'ils
m'aident à réaliser ce souhait
d'augmentation et puis si tenté que
demain l'augmentation devienne
véritablement une réalité imaginons j'ai
effectivement pu me faire imputer les
quatre membres pour les remplacer par
des membres beaucoup plus performant
bien j'ai un accident je me faire
renverser par une voiture
va-t-on considérer qu'il s'agit d'un
dommage corporel
c'est à dire une atteinte au corps et
âme à personne où va-t-on considérer
qu'il s'agit d'une atteinte matériel un
dommage aux biens
cette question elle est importante parce
que endroits de la qualification va
découler en régime et donc les règles
qu'on va appliquer vont être différentes
selon la qualification
alors aujourd'hui il existe évidemment
déjà des prothèses comme celle ci ces
prothèses
aujourd'hui elles sont assimilées à la
personne ça se comprend aisément
en revanche les prothèses utilisé dans
une perspective augmente hâtive comme
dans ce cas là où un musicien utilise un
troisième bras robotique pour jouer de
la batterie ou dans cette hypothèse là
où un artiste utilise un troisième bras
robotique pour faire une oeuvre d'art
ces prothèses la doit-on les assimiler à
la personne est-ce qu'elles relèvent pas
plutôt d'un instrument d'une chose
deuxième axe idéologique c'est la quête
de l'immortalité
la quête de l'immortalité dans sa
dernière campagne d' affiches
publicitaires l'association française du
transhumanistes ad révélé en slogan qui
dit nous voulons tout et tout
vivre vieux mais nous nous ne voulons
pas être vieux autrement dit les
transhumanistes rêve d'une société dans
laquelle il n'y a plus de vieillissement
il n'y a plus de maladies et une société
où nous nous sommes immortel alors je
vous laisse un peu imaginer les
conséquences de la mort de la mort ou du
moins de l'allongement extrêmes de la
vie et les conséquences de la mort halle
de la mort sur le système juridique
exemple si demain la mort disparaît et
bien évidemment il y aura plus droit des
successions
premier exemple si demain la mort
disparaît vont apparaître des problèmes
de surpopulation des problèmes de
concentration de richesse entre la main
deux premières populations d'immortels
etc etc
soit autant de situations qui vont
interroger le droit mais de manière
peut-être un peu moins utopique et de
manière plus concrète la quête de
l'immortalité pose déjà au droit des
questions plus réel ces questions elles
sont liées notamment au développement
d'une technologie en particulier celles
ci cette technologie c'est la
cryogénisation la cryogénisation c'est
une technique de conservation des corps
morts par le froid et cette technique
elle est promue est utilisée par
certains transhumanistes qui estime que
enfin qui espère surtout que demain la
science et les avancées technologiques
permettront de les ramener à la vie
alors aujourd'hui elle n'est pas légale
en france mais elle est autorisée dans
d'autres pays notamment en russie ou aux
états unis
la question qu'on se pose nos juristes
français c'est tout simplement doit-on à
légaliser et si oui si on en vient à
légaliser quel statut
doit-on reconnaître à l'être humain
cryogénisé crio préserver est ce qu'on
doit considérer
continuez pardon elle considérait comme
une personne c'est à dire comme un être
titulaires de droits et d'obligations
ou est-ce qu'on doit le considérer
plutôt comme un cadavre étant entendu
que le cadavre en droit est assimilée à
une chose
et étant donné qu'il n'est ni tout à
fait vivant ni tout à fait mort en tout
cas dans son esprit puisque
potentiellement susceptibles de revenir
à la vie que doit-on faire de son
patrimoine ouvre ton sa succession que
fait-on de ses biens dernier axe
idéologique c'est l'idée du dépassement
de l'homme c'est l'idée que puisque
l'homme est obsolète
il faut le dépasser il faut aller au
delà de l'humain créé mieux que l'humain
pour cela il faut accéder à une post
humanité et pour accéder à cette post
humanité
il ya deux moyens le premier consiste à
partir de l'homme pour accéder à une
forme de surhomme donc on va substituer
homo sapiens par une espèce poste
sapiens cette espèce post sapiens elle
aurait été créé par l'un par la
pénétration au sein de la vie des
sciences et des techniques
donc elle sera constituée entre autres
d'un augmenté c'est à dire un de cyborg
mécanique elle pourrait être constitué
aussi pourquoi pas de clown ou encore de
chimères qui sont des créatures mi homme
mi animal
ça c'est pour la première manière
d'accéder à un surhomme puis la deuxième
manière d'accéder un surhomme c'est
cette fois non plus de partir de l'homme
mais de partir de la machine de partir
de la machine et de la faire accéder à
une forme de vie non organiques alors
très concrètement et ben on va créer un
robot qui non seulement une apparence
humaine
mais même pas nécessairement mais qui en
plus et surtout sera doté d'intelligence
alors je vous ai mis une image du robot
sofia roux sofia on en a beaucoup
entendu parler dans les médias notamment
parce que sofia s'est vu octroyer la
citoyenneté saoudienne bon justement
c'est sur ces questions là que nous on
s'intéresse juristes si demain une
société post humaine arrive et qu'on a
des entités post-humaine les questions
qu'on se pose est de savoir justement
comment on doit les considérer est ce
qu'on doit aller considéré à l'égal des
humains et donc leur octroyer des droits
ou est-ce qu'on doit continuer
les traiter comme des choses et si tant
est qu'on accepte de leur conférer des
droits devra tout donner les mêmes
droits à l'homme augmenté qui est un
homme plus plus finalement corobo qui
n'a aucune composante d'humanité enfin
les auteurs et la doctrine qui réfléchit
sur ces questions là se questionne aussi
sur le fait de savoir si l'apparition
d'une humanité augmenter ne va pas en
parallèle contribué à rabaisser
l'humanité n'ont augmenté vers une forme
dessous du mann heat et finalement la
question qui se pose c'est est ce qu'on
ne va pas voir se raviver une société de
m et d'esclaves je vais vous laisser sur
ces dernières interrogations ovocytes
encore même une phrase de kevin warwick
le cybernéticiens dont je vous parlais
un peu plus tôt et qui est pour sa part
convaincu que ceux qui refuseront de
s'augmenter constitueront une
sous-espèce et seront je vous le site
les chimpanzés de demain merci
[Applaudissements]